hi Linda welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
well thank you Dave I'm hoping you can
answer a question for me I've been
listening for every time I listen to you
and I haven't heard an answer yet
well I'll try okay many years ago I took
out an IRA and it's done deplorable it
was up as high as 50,000 and it's down
it was well I don't know what it is
right now but it was down to 10 because
of all the things that were going on in
the country and everything I guess and
maybe I had had a bad one I don't know
but at any rate I I took it and I rolled
it over into a 50% gold 50% silver IRA
and my husband thinks I've lost my mind
so I wondered if you could maybe at
least explain to me why gold and silver
are bad two reasons one is as a track
record if you look over 50 years they
have a lousy track record as a rate of
return all the money the gold is made it
is made in the last eight years and so
that's the reason reason number one and
I buy investments based on track record
I buy real estate based on what's called
a good neighborhood how do we describe a
good neighborhood one that's taken care
of and it goes up in value yeah versus a
bad neighborhood one that's not taking
care of and going down in value we're
looking at the track record over the
last so many years and that's how that's
how I analyze investments and how I was
taught to do that in academia now then
the second reason is is that gold and
silver precious metals commodities of
that type do not have intrinsic value
meaning they don't create anything it's
a gold rock and so as a concept it's not
throwing off money can I ask you a quick
question on rapture I thought that
silver was being used in a lot of things
like cell phones and computers it is and
that's part of what's driven that has
driven silver up is the actual
utilitarian use of it but even in that
case it's just a commodity and what that
means is the only thing that causes the
price
to go up as a supply demand curve if
there's more demand than there is supply
the price goes up
that's why but barrels of oil go up I
see but even though they have a
utilitarian value to be turned into
gasoline versus a stock in a company the
company is actually generating money
it's actually making money and so you
can do a mathematical formula with the
profits to give the stock of value gold
is merely fear or greed and the same
with silver with the exception of the
utilitarian use so I don't think you're
crazy I just wouldn't have it there I
don't own any of either this is the Dave
Ramsey show